knew some said today on ktla shout out
to ktla knew some piece of [ __ ] but um
handsome devil though handsome [ __ ]
dude i'll give him that oh she went so
[ __ ] handsome this guy looks like his
son what are you a [ __ ] model you're
distracting dude what are you a model
what are you the next captain america
what's happening right now
are you the voice of the new buzz
lightning
sir you are breathtaking
jesus christ
trying to contain this erection but
these [ __ ]
tight pants are giving it away
you guys should all get a good look at
this gentleman out there i don't know
what you do man but skye is the limit by
that
i mean the next top gun [ __ ] sakes
dude
on your helmet just says dime piece
that'd be [ __ ] sick
god i'm just [ __ ] okay dude
it's like i'm not even gaming [ __ ] dude
few drinks and it's going down homeboy
your drinks going down maverick you know
what i'm saying dude
i'll be your bottom gun you feel me
where was i
oh you're distracting dude
you're like a hot medusa get out of here
bro
get your dick out of my face dude
jesus christ man
let me try to i'm just gonna hold this
here so it blocks you out
you're one lucky lady
do not leave your man around me
[Laughter]
right now you live in the green room
it's going down dude
i'm a black belt karate
i don't know if that means anything
god quite the life my man
are you an actor are you a model
dude i'm gonna call tommy hill figure
out when we leave here like
i got the guy bro
you know who could use his abercrombie i
don't know if you saw that documentary
they need some help
[ __ ] who couldn't you help maybe even
seaworld
they're at an all-time low man that
blackfish dock really [ __ ] up
shift shamu what's your name
garrett [ __ ] yeah
i'm just gonna put you in a bathing suit
come see garrett jump into the water
he's [ __ ] splashing around
short shorts
your girl's all mad like [ __ ] whatever
toss in fish in the water and you don't
eat them
just chum in the water
and my big ass just cannonballs in and
[ __ ]
that's my man
just gets gay
sea world gay
[Music]
sorry man you're so distracted dude
the first first ever having a crowd
after seven years i might have to export
you out here you might have to [ __ ]
leave dude
i can't focus man do you like ferraris i
have one
[Music]
where was i
oh yeah talking about handsome people
the shop household we can't go through
in our lockdown tell you right now we're
not going to make it out of it
don't be locked down dude i'm just
saying if you want to lock down i'm i'm
in dude
if they
i'm gonna dm you dude
i'm like hey man i'm thinking about
locking us down what do you think bro
[ __ ] xbox live
bunch of snacks
like probably not much right i i eat
sugar you're into sugar or no you tell
me you're in the gushers
we're [ __ ] dude
if you tell me you like dunkaroos we're
getting married
[Music]
sir i will lick your [ __ ] i'll tell
you that
[Applause]
i hate to keep going your way but i'm
telling you dude
you name your prize daddy
i'm in man